parce que nos villes se transforment
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
iprema votre partenaire pour un
développement
durable bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
équilibre votre magazine sur
l'environnement ce mois-ci nous allons
tenter de consommer local pendant les
fêtes face au gaspillage et scandales
alimentaire à l'agriculture intensive et
à l'appauvrissement de l'économie locale
certains n'hésitent pas à changer leurs
habitudes et des solutions alternatives
se mettent en place pour en parler nous
nous rendrons à manilamoau pour
présenter les AMAP avec le co-président
île-de-fance Alain levotte nous irons
ensuite acheter un sapin yelinois chez
Daniel Barbier à Saint-Lambert des bois
mais tout de suite nous partons à la
rencontre de producteur en circuit court
reportage Pascal leco est producteur de
foie gras à basinville ces produits il
les vend directement sur sa ferme c'est
ce qu'on appelle le circuit court panne
intermédiaire entre lui et ses
consommateurs et un rapport direct avec
ses clients pour expliquer ou faire
visiter son exploitation chez lui le
foie gras est traditionnel les canards
sont nourris avec des céréales locales
et du maïs entier produit et séché
directement dans sa ferme un mode de
fabrication qui permet un FO gras de
et les cents apprécient les gens
aujourd'hui veulent savoir où ils
achètent et ils ne veulent plus des
transports un terminaux dans des
conditions plus moins douteuses et puis
parfois des produits dont c'est pas
réellement l'origine quoi aujourd'hui il
veulent savoir d'où ça vient et ils
veulent que ce soit de la qualité ils
ont raison aujourd'hui on est même
approché de plus en plus par la grand
distribution qui voudrait qu'on produise
un peu mais de toute façon ce sera qu'un
tout petit peu pour eux parce qu'on peut
pas on n' pas les capacités de le faire
et après on on dévaloriserait notre
produit si on se mettait à faire des
quantités trop importantes la qualité de
son foie gras a cependant un cout en
moyenne ces produits sont de 30 à 50 %
plus cher que dans une grande
surface chez Stéphane rousse éleveur
d'escargot à 100 LCE c'est le même tarif
à la caisse pour exemple il faut
débourser un peu plus de 7 € pour une
douzaine de ces gastéropodes en grande
surface on tourne plus aux environs de 4
€ le facteur prix n'est donc pas
négligeable pourtant la demande ne cesse
de croître face aux avantages que
procure ce mode de production l'avantage
c'est d'abord de pouvoir tout toutavoir
une excellente traçabilité ça c'est la
première chose pour le client c'est une
volonté personnelle de pouvoir produire
quelque chose de A à Z et c'est très bon
on met tout notre cœur et c'est très bon
on entend tellement de chos à la
télévision où on lit dans les journaux
et qui est réel qu'on mange de la
saloperie tout ce que nous on pourra
faire de bon ou le meilleur possible
sera un plus que ça soit au niveau
qualité
gustative même le coût petit à petit on
va pouvoir peut-être peut-être baisser
un poil nos cûts pour avoir des produits
plus compétitifs les sort des
plateformes de vente sur Internet comme
par exemple la ruche qui dit oui permet
également pour beaucoup le développement
du circuit court un circuit court qui
crée aussi de l'emploi au niveau local
en moyenne un couple d'exploitants
recrute un ou deux employés sur son lieu
de production et d'après le ministère de
la agriculture en 2012 un producteur
français sur 5 vendait déjà en circuit
court soit près de 107000
exploitants autre solution en vogue pour
relocaliser son alimentation les AMAP
présentation du concept avec le
co-président île-de-fance Alain
levot Alain levotte bonjour bonjour
Olivier avant toute chose pour présenter
le sujet qu'est-ce qu'une AMAP alin
leevot une AMAP comme son nom l'indique
c'est une Association pour le Maintien
de la l'agriculture paysane donc
l'objectif de ces adhérences c'est
l'agriculture et l'agriculture de
proximité euh si possible en bio et en
circuit court comment se met-elle en
place cette AMAP euh et bien ce sont des
groupes de consommateurs qui se
réunissent et qui disent voilà on veut
manger autrement on veut aider notre
agriculture à à se péréniser et par
conséquent on se réunit et on passe des
contrats en direct avec un agriculteur
avec un producteur en général on
commence par le maréchage mais il y a
d'autres productions possibles justement
c'est ça l'intérêt pour les pour les
consommateurs le principal intérêt le
principal intérêt c'est d'avoir la
volonté effectivement de maintenir notre
agriculture telle qu'elle était dans le
passé de manger surtout sainement d'où
l'idée du du
bio les prix est-ce que c'est forcément
plus cher qui fixe d'ailleurs les les
prix est-ce que ce sont les agriculteurs
ou les groupes de consommateurs et bien
je vous dirai les deux c'est-à-dire que
les prix ne sont pas plus élevés que
tous les secteurs bio du du secteur
marchand hein les prix sont fixés d'un
comme un accord entre le producteur et
les consommateur l'idée étant que le
producteur puisse vivre de sa récolte
donc dans une transparence dans une
confiance qui s'établit les uns avec les
autres on établit les prix dans ces
conditions voilà donc un panier toutes
les semaines pour une famille de 4 5
personnes ça peut varier entre 15 16 17
€ selon ce que l'agriculteur met dedans
quand vous parlez justement de panier ou
qu'est-ce qu'il met dedans l'agriculteur
ben il met les produits qu'il fabrique
en fonction des saisons donc vous
n'aurez pas de tomates au mois de
décembre mais vous aurez des poireaux
entre autres et les productions peuvent
dans certains cas se discuter aussi avec
les entre le producteur et les amapiens
qui qui voudrait avoir tel ou tel
produit et l'agriculteur dit je peux
vous le faire ou je peux pas vous le
faire et cetera voilà alors depuis
combien de temps elles existent ces am
c'est quelque chose qui se met en place
récemment ça existe depuis longtemps
alors la première AMAP en France date de
2001 voyez c'est pas vieux le réseau des
amapiles de France doit dater de mémoire
de 2004 200005 sa création donc c'est
une création extrêmement récente qui
intéresse beaucoup de monde on voit
des des personnes des structures
étrangères venir nous nous solliciter
pour voir comment ça marche par
conséquence c'est quelque chose de tout
à fait récent est-ce que justement
l'État euh permet en tout cas aide au
financement de de cesamap aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui c'est un les modes de
financement des des des structures
associatives sont un peu différentes de
ce qu'elles pouvaient être dans le passé
et il arrive effectivement que aussi
bien de au niveau de l'État que des
régions que des communes il y ait des
des des subventions qui soient accordées
mais d'une façon générale c'est pour des
projets très précis et notamment pour ce
qui concerne le développement de
l'agriculture bio et de l'installation
des agriculteurs puisque c'est une des
fonctions
qu'on se donne dans le réseau des AMAP
de mettre en place de renouveler en
quelque sorte le monde agricole dans le
secteur de petite production au niveau
local Alain levotte qu'est-ce qui va
être fait dans les ivelines je crois
qu'on est sur un site un peu spécial là
voilà alors nous sommes ici à Manil sur
un sur des terrains qui devaent être
constructible à l'époque de la ville
nouvelle voyez et que la commune de
manilé avec le concours de la communauté
d'agglomération qui possède les terrains
on va rendre à la culture et donc on va
essayer effectivement va essayer non
c'est même en phase finale de
réinstaller des agriculteurs ici pour
les productions locales notamment en
AMAP par exemple donc on espère que dans
l'année dans pour cette saison là mais
l'année prochaine parce queil faut
laisser le temps à l'agriculteur de
produire et nous aurons des productions
locales sur menour déjà tout est mis en
place au niveau de de la map alors
l'étude l'étude est en phase finale je
pense mais je faudrait ait poser la
question aux élus plus concrètement je
crois qu'ils doivent désigner dans un
futur proche les les porteur de projet
donc le ou les agriculteurs qui auront
le projet à mettre en œuvre et à partir
de là bah voilà faudra
concrètement la bourrer merci beaucoup
Alain levot pour toutes ces précisions
sur les AMAP et puis bonne continuation
voilà merci à vous pour votre belle
émission et puis j'espère que vous
reviendrez quand on plantera le premier
po on espère aussi
merci à Saint-Lambert des bois Daniel
Barbier produit des sapin yvelinois nous
sommes allés chez lui pour découvrir ses
Norman ses épicas et ses
nobilis un sapin yvelinois pour
accueillir les cadeaux du Père Noël chez
Daniel Barbie à Saint-Lambert des bois
c'est tout à fait possible dans sa
sapinière les arbres sont cultivés sur
place en partie tout fois car Norman
epicea et nobilis n'arrivent seulement
chez lui qu'après quelques années en
pépinière du côté d'Orléan mais une fois
reçus ils passeront un an en peau avant
d'être planté sur son domaine où ils
prendront de 5 à 8 ans pour continuer de
pousser naturellement le sous-sol c'est
sa bleu donc ça draine et le haut
justement c'est une bonne terre à
betterave une terre à rosier donc
justement le le le le le sapin pousse
doucement et par contre l'eau ne reste
ne stagne pas sur le sur la terre ça
c'est très important le problème du
sapin de Noël le sapin lui monte en
flèche passer 7 8 10 ans d'abord on voit
moins tout de suite il monte les flèches
et pour un sapin c'est pas beau d'avoir
simplement une flèche donc il faut
justement qu'il pousse doucement donc
surtout pas d'engrais pesticide c'est
pas besoin donc il y a juste un peu de
taille bio oui oui si on veut mais on
coupe à la tronçonneuse donc il y a un
moteur quand je vais les livrer je suis
avec un camion donc c'est bio
pratiquement à 90 % sûr la coupe des
sapins sur sa plantation s'effectue
comme le veut la période normale pour un
sapin de qualité dès la première
quinzaine de décembre en supermarché et
et en grande jardinerie les sapins de
Noël sont souvent coupés et stockés dès
début novembre ce qui oblige leur
producteur à pulvériser les arbres de
fixateur polluant une différence de
taille quand on sait que les tarifs sont
identiques c'est la fin de ce numéro
d'équilibre espérons qu'il vous donnera
quelques bonnes idées pour les fêtes
mais avant de se quitter on jette un œil
à l'agenda du 26 au 28 décembre
l'atelier à la quête de l'eau va
permettre de façon ludique de faire
comprendre aux participants les
inégalités de l'accès à l'eau dans le
monde et de tenter de trouver des
solutions jusqu'au 28 décembre vous
pouvez toujours découvrir l'exposition
sur l'eau et les hommes expérience à
l'appui venez découvrir ou redécouvrir
que la vie sur Terre est apparue dans
l'eau enfin le 24 janvier prochain une
conférence sur la fertilité des sols
sera tenue par deux ingénieurs agricoles
l'occasion de s'informer sur
l'appauvrissement des terres et de
découvrir des solutions alternatives
voilà pour pour votre programme
environnemental nous on se retrouve le
17 janvier prochain d'ici là nous vous
souhaitons de joyeuses fêtes et une
excellente année 2014 avec bien sûr la
même devise la terre et notre m
respectonsla
salut